hey everybody it's your pop music
hip-hop Maven over here Michael Knowles
there is a new song that is dropped and
I know so many of you love my friend Tom
McDonald but when I heard about this
song I found out not only is it a Tom
McDonald song but it features another
friend of mine Mr John Rich so I'm gonna
try to be impartial put all of my
affection for these gentlemen aside and
give you my highly perceptive modern
cool guy young Zoomer music take take it
away
I know the end is near the television
telling lies I know for sure the
revolution won't be televised I know
that we've been waiting patiently for
better times we fell asleep but men are
blind can't recognized as genocide feel
like the bomb about to drop out of the
clouds and all the virus go on Airborne
go hide inside your house Farmers
watching cops are they drying up with
droughts angry people forming crowds and
trying to burn the cities down this is
Armageddon martial law for our
protection I talked to God but it's long
distance and I lost reception forest
fires and oil spills are the awful
lessons I'm just waiting for the devil
to take over Heaven this is biblical I
swear it's in the Bible we keep killing
one another and we dying for survival we
used to fight for peace we put our
flowers and their rifles now we're about
to be extinct every man woman put a
pause there that's kind of interesting
just as a almost minor political
observation he's talking about bigger
themes but a minor political observation
here is he's pointing out that the
people who used to protest for war
or rather the people who used to protest
against War are now protesting for war
it's all those hippy-dippy flower
children who put the little flowers in
the rifles they're the ones now who have
the Ukraine flag and their bios they're
the ones who are who are clamoring for
more U.S intervention abroad and it's
all those crazy old conservatives who
are saying hey maybe we should stop
being involved in so many wars around
the world and we should focus our
attention home and the reason for that
of course is that the political order
used to be dominated by more
conservative-minded people and
in the latter half of the 20th century
it shifted and the Liberals took over
the
establishment so Roger Kimball refers to
this in Academia as tenured radicals
that the hippie radical students came to
take over the university well it's true
of the whole political order
all the libs who used to protest against
the man well now they are the man
[Music]
if it's the end of the world
after the fullest
we still
we've been to space before we had our
dogs in houses we dug up dinosaurs we
built dogs are dropping we
follow their Wars now that
[Music]
now that did we do it
the pause there
so the verses are a little bit different
for those two stanzas rather the first
one says if it's the end of the world
I'll do better next time oh yeah I know
it yeah I know it if it's the end of the
world I know that I've lived my life to
the fullest yeah the fullest
so I've done if it's the end of the
world and even these images of not just
the bombs dropping but UFOs E.T flying
in it's a it reminds me of another rock
song end of the line by the Traveling
Wilburys where Jeff Lynn when he's
singing his verse he says every day
Judgment Day really it's all right and I
love that line every day is Judgment Day
because death comes as a thief in the
night you never know the time or the
hour and so
you you
don't need to see E.T flying in the sky
or nuclear bombs dropping to know that
at some point your world is going to
come to an end at least and so have you
lived life to the to the fullest have
you lived the right way and then there's
this ambivalence in the second in the
second part we stood on top of mountains
yeah we did it we've been to space
before yeah we did it we had our dogs in
houses yeah we that's true that's how it
used to be now the dogs are in our
houses now we're in the doghouse the
dogs are living in our in our homes we
dug up dinosaurs yeah that's cool we
built the bombs they're dropping hmm
well that's impressive that we built the
bombs but wait a second now that
progress as we perceived of it
is actually harming us and threatening
us and destroying our world we fought in
all their Wars
who's they
I guess the it's the political order
it's the the elites the people who are
running the show we fought in all of
their Wars and we thought it was for us
but then he says
but the sky's falling now
not only in spite of the things that we
did but in in part at least because of
the things we did so what did we do it
for feels like the end is near our
Freedom's disappearance people playing
God call it genetic engineering media
misleading us and evils interfering
while the government we need became the
power that we're fearing our
billionaires are going to space don't
blame them for leaving birds are falling
out the air fish washing up on our
beaches this is end times humans got a
deadline children are the future till we
ruin them with headlines she'll be past
a bedtime but everyone's woke they told
us chase a dollar that made everyone
broke I feel like cryptocurrency is
probably our last Financial hope soon
enough the government will leave your
bank account froze Judgment Day is
coming you can run or you can stand and
fight panic in the darker lead
rebellions by the candlelight this ain't
your Granddaddy's planet Earth it's
black and white the end is coming I'll
see y'all in the afterlife put a pause
there you see he's he's seeing his
freedom slip away and it sounds just
like a meaningless platitude at the top
our freedoms are slipping away yeah
people are always complaining about
their freedom slipping away but then he
cites these specific examples
he says birds are falling out of the
hour fish are washing up on our beaches
so it's not just our freedom to have our
guns and our money and our whatever our
gas stoves it's even the freedom to have
clean air the freedom to have a normal
society that's going away certainly
it's the end time we got a deadline
Children of the future until we ruin
them with headlines and now the kids are
have these really high rates of anxiety
and depression and suicidality and
social media is playing a huge role in
this we're not having children anyway
they told us to chase the dollar but
then
then they're going to freeze us out of
the financial system so he's even saying
even this really basic understanding of
Freedom which is I'm going to keep my
money you better not take my money and
my stuff freedom to make some money with
our labor
even that can all just be taken away
like this because the the political
order now is so centralized that if you
get canceled then it's not only in China
where your social credit score will drop
and you'll be kicked out of society it's
here in the United States
you'll be de-platformed you'll be
debanked you'll be prohibited from
traveling you'll be put on a no-fly list
you're you're there's no escaping it
there's no Go West Young man this is it
there's no West left we settled the West
This is the End Time keep going
[Music]
if it's the end of the world
I just I love that scene
selling the tin foil for five hundred
dollars because because you know these
days the difference between a conspiracy
theory and the truth is about three to
six months and that tin foil the price
is going to go up the markets are going
crazy on all sorts of Commodities and
metals and I think 10 is going to see a
real surge at the end of days okay keep
going
[Music]
it's yours we
all their Wars now
guys
we know it it's awful that it's over
so you see the classic rebellion of Tom
and Tom looks like a young doesn't
doesn't look the most conservative let's
say with all the tattoos and everything
and what's his response to this to the
people who are going to come kill him
and take away his way of life it's to
flip him the bird then you turn to John
Rich who looks extremely conservative in
the American understanding he's got the
big cowboy hat he's got his guitar he's
a country boy and what does he do he
takes a rock and throws it at that UFO
and the UFO starts to tip around he says
you know it's the end of days okay it's
all closing in but I don't need to
Ascent to that you can take away all my
freedoms but you can't take away my
freedom of conscience you can't take
away the freedom of my mind and so you
can kill me okay fine but I'm not going
to agree to it I'm not going to just
roll over there's a story it may be
apocryphal it may not
of an opera singer in Nazi Germany who
didn't want to perform when the Nazis
were were at her show and some Nazi
representative goes backstage and said
we will make you sing Go on stage we
will make you sing and she said you can
make me scream
but you cannot make me sing
and say I you can't take away that that
ultimate Freedom that I have for myself
and Tom and John both saying the same
thing to the aliens while we look down
at our phones they'll drop a bomb from a
drone and an explosion we should have
known it
foreign
[Music]
this isn't just an expression of
resentment
what did we do it for it was all for not
I think it's a sincere question well
yeah what did we do it for because some
of that stuff sounds pretty good did we
do it for
the political rulers who turned on us I
hope that's not the only reason that
we've explored things and climbed
mountains and used our reason dug up
dinosaurs reasoned about the world had
our homes had our dogs defended our I
hope that's I hope there's something
deeper is it because we love our fellow
citizens we love our family we love God
we love the good I what did we do it for
I know we did it and I think there was a
reason we did it but the reason wasn't
just to appease these terrible people
who very often control the political
order
[Music]
I like that I really like it it's
fabulous I love the whole way the video
is shot and excellent performances
from both Tom and John
and rug it does get it's a very funny
song and a funny video and it's supposed
to be funny and weird it's got cows
being beamed up onto spaceships and you
know people flipping off aliens and
stuff so it's very funny but it's
thought provoking so it's a more
complicated song than than you might
think given the how common the first few
lines are I think that's kind of a way
to lull you in to to have you think more
deeply a very it's a tricky song all
right that's it we'll see you next time
[Music]
my life to the fullest
yeah the fullest